Welcome to another edition of the Tim Ferriss show.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I would like to start this very special episode with two things.
First,
a quote and that is quote,
be who you are and say what you feel because those who mind don't matter and
those who matter don't mind and quote from none other than Dr Seuss.
Love that quote.
Second,
just a little bit of trivia since the coauthor of what I learned,
losing $1 million is our guest today.
I thought I would look at the number 1 million,
the denomination,
1 million.
It's a big deal in the U S and a lot of western culture,
but perhaps you didn't know that the number 10,000 is a very big deal in for
instance,
Japan and when they say Bonzai Bonzai when they throw their arms up in the air,
that is button or like Iti Bong been 10,000 years,
Xy Bonzai 10,000 years,
10,000 years.
So there you have it,
a quote and a random piece of trivia that you can play with this episode.
We have Brendan Moynahan with us.
Brennan Moyninhan is a managing director at market field asset management,
which has $20 billion or so of assets under management.
He's also the senior advisor to the editor and chief of Bloomberg News.
He's an adjunct professor at Vanderbilt University where he teaches both
international finance investment analysis.
And previous to all of that he spent more than 20 years on Wall Street as a
trader and risk manager.
He's written a whole slew of books,
mostly on finance and investing.
But the one that I want to highlight today is what I learned losing $1 million.
And as you'll hear in the interview,
this is one of the few books in existence that has been praised by Nassim Taleb
who is author of the Black Swan or is author of the Black Swan among others.
And uh,
it was labeled by him,
one of the rare non Sharla tannic books and finance.
What does that mean?
Well,
I chase down this book when it wasn't in print and read it and had a huge impact
on me.
So much so that it is one of the few books in the Tim Ferriss Book Club.
I,
it is the newest book in the Tim Ferriss Book Club and there are 1,000,001 ways
to make money and as a result there are a million in one way is to publish books
about varying methods of success,
making money and so on.
As it turns out,
it's perhaps a much smarter approach to look at the few ways in which people
consistently lose money consistently make big trading mistakes,
investment mistakes,
business mistakes that cost them money.
So if you can identify the principle ways that people lose money and in this
case the other coauthor Jim Paul had us a really dramatic story of losing more
than a million dollars that you can then define rules for yourself that allow
you to be a better investor,
a better business person and in general succeed better in life.
Pretty fascinating stuff.
So Brendan is our guest today.
I hope you enjoy it.
As always,
this podcast is supported by you guys.
If you like these podcasts,
both the short inbetween Assos,
the longer interviews,
please take a look at the Tim Ferriss Book Club.
Just go to four hour work,
week.com all spelled out,
four hour workweek.com forward slash books you will find about a half dozen
books that have had a huge impact on my life,
including this book,
what I learned,
losing $1 million.
And if you click on those,
it'll take you through to Amazon.
And that keeps this podcast going because it does take a lot of time and some
capital to put together.
So without further ado,
I introduce you to Brendan Monaghan.
Enjoy
at this altitude.
I can flat out hands start shaking.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living this show.
Well,
welcome everyone
[inaudible] to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show and I'm very excited to
have Brendan Moynahan with us today.
Brendan,
how are you
doing?
Extremely well and I am thrilled to be chatting with you because of course I was
introduced to your work first through what I learned,
losing $1 million and I remember being introduced to it by an intolerable
naissant Taleb who wrote of course antifragile then before that,
the Black Swan and then fooled by randomness.
And one of the lines that stuck out in his most recent book about what I learned
losing $1 million was that it was one of the rare non Charlotte tannic if that's
the correct pronunciation,
books and finance.
And I was hoping before we jump into all sorts of other questions that I'd like
to ask,
why do you think he said that?
Why do you think he used that particular adjective?
I had never met him when he puts the title of my book,
the Black Swan and at that time he said it was the best non Shawl Atlantic
finance book you've ever read.
And it was actually that mention that cause a little bit of a struggle with
email for me to reprint the book.
So we put in the book based on what happened in the Black Swan.
And then a few years later he was at an interview with a desert as a journalist
at Bloomberg News.
And I happened to be a consultant there at the time and they invited me to sit
in on a lunch and he recognized my name when I was introduced just because he
had put it in his book.
So I never really queried him about,
I mean I was thankful that he did it because he's not known for handing out
compliment.
So
happy to
have had it and I wasn't going to jinx it,
but we had a vigorous discussion while we were in that room and it turns out
that he's read a lot of the same things that I've read.
And so it was sort of a dialogue between him and me while the reporters were
kind of taking notes,
which is very interesting.
So I don't know why he did that,
but when I think that it's because was an opposite tact and that there's so many
books out there on how I made $1 million in the stock market last year before
breakfast.
And in the million dollar book that I wrote,
I even go back and try to find out how old is this?
And there's a book from like 1881 I think by James Briskin called the beef
bonanza,
how to get rich on [inaudible]
place.
It wasn't the stock market,
livestock,
the market,
but people have been forever.
Like,
I'm going to tell you my secrets of how I got rich.
I don't understand that.
So I titled this book,
What I learned,
losing $1 million with my coauthor.
Again,
Jim lost the money,
not me.
I want to be clear about that.
But why would somebody revealed their secrets to making it?
Why don't we examine what goes wrong?
And then if somebody is willing to bare their soul about that and share the
mistakes,
then as a parable,
it might have more resonance with people about what not to do rather than what
to do.
And I think there's a,
I'll get into it later,
but he was a real premise for why it's essential to know the downside rather
than all the different ways to make it on the upside.
Well,
I think it's funny.